hundreds of African migrants say they've
been expelled from Tunisia and are now
stranded at the Libyan border they say
they're being forced to drink sea water
to survive and Libyan border guards
refuse to let them in let's get more on
this story with Malik trainer who joins
us from the Tunisian Libyan border hello
there Malik you saw those people in dire
need of help can you tell us a little
bit more about their situation now
well they are in dire need of help we
went and spoke to them uh the hundreds
we couldn't tell you exactly how many of
you but at the specific spot where we
were at we saw hundreds of them in in
desperate and dire conditions many
without food and water for six days uh
we saw people that were injured we saw
people we saw women and children uh and
the situation looks like it's only
getting worse I mean they're really
they're stuck in limbo what we could
clearly see was Tunisian border patrols
and Libyan and and on the other side
Libyan and they were stuck in the middle
the tunisians were pushing them towards
the Libyan side the Libyan side was not
allowing them to enter
so I mean this situation I you know
people are are really uh especially uh
activists and human rights organizations
are really worried that uh unless a
situation is found soon unless some kind
of humanitarian assistance can reach
these people uh you know they're gonna
suffer from dehydration from from famine
I mean it's extremely hot right now and
uh the terrain that they're in is is
Desert it's hot the sun is just glaring
at them so the situation is really
desperate for these hundreds of people
yeah it certainly doesn't look like they
have any shelter as well Malik what is
Libby is saying particularly given the
allegations it's now ignoring its
International obligations
well we spoke to Libyan officials here
and what they were telling us is that
listen these these people are irregular
migrants but they're on the Tunisian
they're on Tunisian territory uh you
know when we spoke to the director of
the of the uh of the border the Russian
border here on the Libyan side he said
he said we like any state do not allow
people to enter our territory without
legal travel documentation without
proper you know visas or passports uh so
you know the libyans are saying that you
know we we have we have the we have the
right to refuse to refuse entry to to
people who who don't have uh uh uh don't
have the proper paperwork
but at the end of the day really I mean
you know it's the tunisians expelling
these people and the libyans not
allowing them to enter so they're just
stuck in no man's land with no
humanitarian Assistance or no help and
no and and really no nobody or no
there's there's there's no solution in
sight unless the tunisians and libyans
are able to talk to them to talk to each
other come to some kind of agreement and
figure a solution out for these people
let's hope it happens soon thanks so
much for the update Malik trainer on the
Tunisian Lillian border